he's Dan Hicks he's NBC Sports lead golf
play-by-play man and getting ready for
the Ryder Cup in France coming up on
Friday and he joins us now dan how are
you today I'm spectacular if you didn't
watch yesterday how would you sum up
what you saw I would sum it up by saying
you're probably not gonna see anything
like it no not probably you'll never see
anything like it again because you'll
never be to come back because that
happened yesterday now I know a lot of
people think it's not official till he
gets a major but you're never gonna see
anything like that from a 5 plus year
drought - what Tigers been through - the
new tiger who presented himself I think
to a lot of people yesterday in a way
that they have not seen him in his
previous 79 wins so I think if you you
know if you missed yesterday or if you
wanted to sum it up you would simply say
it's a once-in-a-lifetime viewing
experience it was that special and yes
you're as you're seeing this crowd it's
almost like the British Open where they
they sort of give birth to the champion
when he kind of emerges out of the crowd
there but when you start to see this
swell what are you thinking as Tigers
walking up a team I'm thinking the same
thing everybody else is I couldn't
believe what I was seeing and I mean
when those ropes went down and those
people now obviously that doesn't happen
with any other golfer it's not like
we've seen that scene in past 2 or
Championships it's just not gonna happen
but that was the enthusiasm all week and
it was it was even more special because
Tiger had to lead from the get-go this
was a wire-to-wire win so this whole
thing had been brewing and I had had a
chance to go to the practice tee every
day my schedule allowed that so it was
neat to see Tiger warm-up and appear on
the practice tee every day and so when I
went out there there were people
literally waiting 2-3 hours just for his
appearance on the practice tee with
their cell phones out as he was going to
come out and there was a standing
ovation each time he walked out to the
tee I mean
there were stuff going on Dan out there
that you know that we didn't were able
to show with our cameras but just a
comments by people the parents bringing
kids and in these kids seen Tiger Woods
for the first time and and the parents
explaining what this guy is all about
because it had been so long since he'd
done this so it was uh it was special
all the way around I'll never forget it
certainly and I think what is
interesting is if you're 13 or 14 years
of age you have no idea what this is all
about you're seeing something but if
you're a golf fan even if you're 20 you
might have no idea of what Tiger mania
used to be and even these younger
golfers I always did I thought it was
very humorous like Justin Thomas would
say man I'd love to hear those Tiger
wars again Rory talked about that all of
a sudden you're paired next to Tiger and
like oh you asked for it this is what
it's all about we sucked like we saw
what happened to Rory yesterday's
shooting who won at 74 yeah he got he
got caught up in the tiger vortex I mean
here's the guy's 42 years old these guys
have been you know a couple of them have
publicly said hey I'd loved it been
Rory's one of them I'd love to go
head-to-head with Tiger Justin Thomas
said that that's that's my dream going
head-to-head Tiger but look what Tiger
did playing with Dustin Rose he was a
little bit more of his contemporary
Ricky Fowler one of the young guys still
he got caught up in the tiger vortex and
then Rory McIlroy got sucked into it
yesterday and he was just along for the
ride it it's amazing stuff and I think I
think people seeing it for the first
time finally get it what we're talking
about because you know we we kind of get
crushed a little bit by some people out
there that think we're just so Tiger
centric and all we show is Tiger geez
what about these other younger guys
Spieth and Fowler you guys get so caught
up in Tiger well yesterday is a reason
we get caught up and dagger because
there's nothing like him and there's
nobody been there's no one in history
like it and I know that you choose your
words carefully we talked to Steve sands
about this of what kind of comeback this
this is not just golf and I mentioned
Ben Hogan who nearly died but you know a
lot of this wood Tiger was
self-inflicted but still it's still a
incredible comeback and and can you
label it the greatest sports comeback of
Ault
yeah it's difficult and it was so crazy
yesterday that you know it would have
been it would have been nicer to have a
little more time to try to put that in
perspective but here's what I would say
about comebacks and anybody that argues
that this wasn't one of the greatest if
not the greatest you could talk about
Ben Hogan that was you know a near-death
experience obviously and you can bring
in all sorts of others Muhammad Ali
Monica Seles but no one comes close to
going through the public scrutiny and
the humiliation again brought on by
Tiger but you have to factor that in in
this day and age of the social media and
not only the original you know downfall
back in November of the fire hydrant
episode but just 16 months ago with the
mug shot that made its way around the
the internet you cannot deny that the
physical comeback the fort Baxter
resolved in these surgeries and all that
physical stuff is huge but no one has
gone through that kind of humiliation
and it's it's so important obviously for
any athlete to have confidence and feel
that way and that's what Tiger built his
entire career on was having that
impenetrable confidence that he was
going to get it done yeah that was all
torn to the ground he had to build it up
it's not the same as it was and it never
will be but it had to get to a point
where he could have the confidence in
his game to put it out there in a big
tournament like yesterday and get it
done so comebacks no one's come back
from that kind of thing and also you
have the writer cup coming up I don't
know if there's a hangover or is it
momentum for the US team because you saw
a lot of those golfers who stayed just
to congratulate him that it just feels
the Ryder Cup feels a little different
now because now you got the hammer there
where is you couldn't count on anybody
in that US lineup where you go I I can
count on it it feels like Tiger is back
to the and his Ryder Cup record is not
great but still I'm curious about that
momentum as you guys go to France what
do you expect
yeah it's always tough to gauge there's
been a lot of golf played this stretch
of the season Tigers played more golf
than he has in five six years
jordan Spieth was not even a part of the
Tour Championship so he's got arrested
but most of these guys the majority of
the guys that you saw I could be the
Tour Championship this week from Europe
and the US I put a lot of golf and never
know you know what's going to happen
over the Patrick Reed wasn't on his game
at the Tour Championship but he's a guy
that's thriving in the Ryder Cup
atmosphere and Tiger you know we'll see
you know it's going to be really
interesting because I think you could
throw out the book on Form I think you
can throw out the book on you know what
history what Tigers record is even what
Phil's record is and phil Mickelson's
record is certainly not stellar but he's
played on more Ryder Cups in our will
than anybody in the history of the sport
and I just think that the moon and the
stars are aligned with everybody that's
been playing so well for the most part
and the bull and and what both teams are
comprised of the stars and the
personalities and tiger and Phil back
this is probably gonna be the last time
you see tiger and Phil on a Ryder Cup
team I just don't think that you know
you know Phil is I think this is Phil's
last run so you know enjoy it you know
just like we enjoyed Tigers victory
yesterday you never know how many
there's gonna be and enjoy this Ryder
Cup because this is gonna be pretty
special I think safe travels down it was
great listen this weekend thanks for
joining us yeah good to hear that Steve
Sands is still very high up on the all
lovin that's because he's I think he's a
future hall-of-famer I think that he's
got that kind of potential but you were
always working late you had all the
swimming events you were never I never
saw all lobby bar I think you know you
know I I think the all Lobby team is you
got to pretty much remember that there's
obviously not you know enough of a
demanding Olympic assignment for for
those people that can make the all lobby
squads like Steve Sands we got it you
know you're going to see Bob Costas or
Mike Tirico throw him back he's all
night long at the Olympics you're just
you're just not going to enjoy those
kinds of moments so Steve Sands rise to
the occasion again pal the next Olympics
in Tokyo okay if you walked
the bar and you saw Bob costis there
bellied up to the bar more reason to
stop or more reason to keep going more
reason to give my brief flame and
personation of him such as Bob is there
any way I can perhaps buy you a beer or
are you taking a break from beer and
going pure wine on these particular
Olympic Games back after this in Florida
thank you Dan safe travels where did
this interview go it went right down the
- I have no idea okay great great to
talk to you and good being in your
former town of Atlanta this week and by
the way tell tell my wife Hannah that I
sent alone Dan Hicks
well back story there had some people
who still believe a Don Imus thought for
ever radio host thought that Hannah was
married to me technically never married
to you never I don't think not even in
like a short ceremony like you know
Johnny no what was it to Winona Ryder
and Kenna Reeves in a movie got married
and then they thought it might hold up
or something but don't who was it
somebody else who thought that Hannah
was my wife Oh Hannah
that's right thought you know I'm
kidding for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]